we turn back to the phone lines one of
our favorite guests and we always
appreciate when the
pittsburgh steelers uh are performing
well because of this guy james connor
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you james
how you doing brother i am doing fine um
so uh
we we heard so much last night about the
titans and everything that they were
going through
um and how their schedule uh got
rearranged
um they were dealing with covet you were
just
part of all that because the schedule
had you playing the titans at that point
in time
how have the last couple of weeks and
then your readiness
uh in the game against the eagles walk
me through all that how tomlin handled
that and how your
team handled its business there james um
you know we kind of
you know had that five weeks just
throwing up on us quick you know earlier
than we expected
you know but we just adjust and that's
uh you know that's one thing that this
team is good at we just been uh
been able to adjust on the goal on the
fly and uh maximize
our time a way that we had uh during
that bye week
um and so yeah we were able to you know
come out and get a win versus
philadelphia
and so really everything else was just
you know kind of just noise we uh
as long as we want to take care of
business and and we and we did that
and so now we're just going from here
but it was um you know we had that five
weeks earlier than we expected but
uh it's just it's just part of the game
part of the this environment that we're
in right now
of course and we in the media all you
know we talked about
uh in regards to that with your team was
mike tomlin saying we do not care
that's what he said just simply we do
not care
um did he did you pick that up through
the media or did he
actually deliver that in a speech to you
guys at some point
well we knew that that's his attitude
you know through uh regardless of what
the situation was um
you know we he told you to explain that
to us realize that what we're going to
do
you know what's happening by week
already and um at the end of the day if
we want to you know be
world champs that's what we're going to
have to do is is go you know make this
stretch and so uh
we we took the challenge we challenge it
head on
and uh yeah we're just going to go so uh
big ben looks to be
no worse than where he looks the same to
me how does he look to you
james uh it looks like ben
roethlisberger again you know
kind of thing around uh taking control
of our offense
i win the game score so it's a
collective effort but uh it's always
nice to have our leader back and uh
you know you know my short time here so
far he looks like ben
no i know i know you got banged up in
that first game against the giants
but did you have a moment in that game
where he made a play
made a throw said something in the
huddle where you're like okay we're good
at that did anything happen there um
kind of just pregame
you know letting him letting us know you
know wonder why he
he came back and it was for us you know
it's for to take charge and lead us to a
world champion you know he already has
those
and um you know he's so he really just
confessed that you know he's doing it
for us and so that uh that let us know
that okay you know
he's already accomplished everything
that he wanted to do but he came back
you know for us so i kind of knew right
then and there
no i know he said that in the media but
did he say that to you like literally
sat everyone down on a zoom or in person
when you were able to be in person to
say such a thing
james we uh are our present songs yep
and that monday that monday night that's
what he said before you went out on the
field
yeah he just let us know that ours you
know he came back for us and
and uh yeah that he's deeply you know
he's playing for us this year
okay james connor leader right here on
the rich eisen show um
and then are you uh getting banged up in
that first game i just
just looking at your face um you had to
be sitting there going you've got to be
kidding me but
you know um tomlin said we'll leave the
door open for him
and boy did you walk back through it
james walk me through that how you dealt
with that adversity at the beginning of
this season
oh yeah it was frustrating when it first
happened you know
don't know no like don't like injuries
obviously but um
it was just uh you know like slight
ankle issues so i'm just thankful for
that
uh could have been a lot worse and
there's been some tragic injuries around
the league this year
um so i just uh wanted to get back and
you know get back healthy first and
foremost and then just go out there and
try to contribute to that run game to
you know to this team and so uh just
trying to put it together find my groove
and just keep stacking these wins so um
chase claypool was on yesterday he seems
like a delightful
canadian human being he seems like just
a great
person james and uh that good things
should happen too
um so what's what was his performance
like from your perspective
man i uh we kind of understood that with
when he first stepped in um just his
size and speech and strength
um and just his willingness to learn and
get better and grow and so i'm very
excited for him
and then just happy that he's on our
side you know anytime i get four
touchdowns you know it makes things
easier so um
he's a playmaker happy he's with us and
i know he's gonna make a lot more plays
in the future you know
he's also a good person as well as
football player does he have a nickname
uh maple tron he go about make patron he
does go by mapletron because that was
part of the conversation
he does now he don't go by that but i'll
call him that he don't really get a
choice
oh you call him back did you come up
with that or or
was that just no that's his thing that's
his line i don't take no credit for the
other thing he might have some
merchandise
uh uh some clothing with clothing line
that said that so
that's his thing so mapletron it is
because he's
he's big he's physical isn't he he's a
big dude
so mapletron it is okay we'll go with
that um
james connor here on the rich eisen show
and then defensively
um do you know what do you
i mean what do you think of when you
watch your guys uh out there when you're
standing there
or you know you're out of the playbook
you're out of looking at
you know whatever plays on the screens
that you need to do uh getting ready for
your next series
what what is it like what your
perspective you got a good story about
watching these guys and
and how the defense yes
man i just i just i just expect big
plays i expect big plays
might expect you know tackle for losses
sacks and every time the qp drives back
man we got a
great defensive line i think it's gonna
be a big way to happen every time i see
it
so i got a lot of confidence in those
guys um you know we
great defense all around so you know um
it's it's fun watching those guys and
just the energy they play with
do you give tj wanting a grief along
with derek that uh
his brother doesn't allow them to talk
on ultimate tag do you give a guys
no no that much okay i just don't know
if you ever caught that show
all right i'm just i'm trying to plumb
the depths here and just how smart is
your middle
linebacker just in terms of intelligence
to devin bush he's pretty smart do you
do you think otherwise
no i'm a michigan man i'm i'm i'm i want
to bring that up
this is okay no i want to sing his
praises and
my guys are laughing that i bring up how
smart he is because i'm a michigan man
and i like bringing up the intelligence
factor of people who want to that
institution of higher learning
james uh that's the smartest part
but on the field no he's that's my man
that was making play back our middle
linebacker man
you know he handles it handles it
handles it all well he sure does
um hey before i let you go uh when was
the last time you spoke to le'veon bell
james carter
um the summer uh training
okay what are you what's your reaction
to the news that the jets have let him
go
um i think that uh i really don't have a
reaction to it i i
know that he probably you know there has
been some communication issues within
that organization for
maybe some time and i don't know if he
wanted to get out there what it was but
um he said he got more football to give
so i'm excited to watch i'm a fan of it
so i just hope everything works out and
i like to see him
you know because he's a talented
football player so i just hope things
work out well for him
so you you because the conversation is
um
you know people are already having that
uh potentially he uh
will take you know he's he's taken a
year off before
do you think he wants to play i mean
again i i i know you don't speak for him
but again you
do know him better than i would that's
for sure i've interviewed him just a
couple of times do you think he he wants
to continue playing
this year best you can tell james oh
yeah he said you know he said himself
that he had you know more to give and so
i know how hard he works i know you know
the shape his body's been
and all of that so i know he still you
know also he still wants to play
and go out there and make plays and
compete
and how much of uh again i know you got
it ready for the cleveland browns
but did uh how much of a conversation
was there in your locker room today for
those who have been around
that overlapped the arrows if you will
like you do
about this i didn't hear nothing about
it we
i didn't know we didn't hear nothing
about it didn't hear nothing about it
just for that practice
no kidding so i'm the first one to bring
it up to you today that's what you're
saying
yeah i mean i've seen it on the tv but
other than that
yeah okay james connor here on the rich
eisen show and then uh that's a grown
ass man that you might be running
towards
uh this coming weekend in miles garrett
what is the challenge
ahead of you in this series that it's
been a very long time since the steelers
and browns have both
been at least three games over 500 this
is a big one james
yeah uh we got a nice challenge ahead um
very talented
you know um it'll be it'll be a good
matchup and whoever whichever team plays
the best i
think it'll come out on top all right
james you take care of yourself thanks
for the call right
your family good everybody good and your
family i believe
you got to go i think you got to go